I understand 41 years in the United
States I was taking over there when I
was four years old when I got here I was
completely discombobulated I got this
job by circumstance literally I was
walking down this street right here the
main boulevard with a bucket of
knowledge standing the palace on the
streets somebody out there tom is saying
you speak English oh yeah I speak
English very well in the matter of fact
then you really you know a lot better
than living in a house with ten people
in the US trying to make up you know
working as a you know dishwasher or
things like that and over here you can
come in and you can you know have a good
lifestyle to have a good pay and then
work in a nice and a nice building you
know with with great people even to this
day I hear the the National handsome I
hear the star-spangled banner and the
laid-back feel right now
she'll scroll up to me and I know we're
here and make it amazing I know deep
down inside of me I'm still in America
if it was 40 years you don't take away
40 years of great to leave this to the
flag in a year and a half